hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in Cicero's work
on fate he's considering a fundamental
metaphysical question namely that of
freedom and determinism freedom of the
human being in their willings actions
desires a sense all these sorts of
things that we typically attribute to
ourselves and the question is is any of
this truly free or is all of this
determined even faded by causes perhaps
those that we don't know but causes that
would exist and which would necessitate
everything that we do and one of the key
thinkers that he examines in there and
really identifies with is carnea days
who was one of the heads or skull arcs
of the academic skeptic school that is
Plato's Academy after had taken a
skeptical turn before it came back to
platonism in middle Platonism and Cicero
himself typically identifies himself
with this school that doesn't mean some
sort of strict party line identification
but he certainly seems to be taking
Kearney a day's line in and this and
what does this thinker have to say you
could I suppose summarize it
by the statement that there is human
freedom and human freedom exists within
a universe that car nyada's has no
problem saying is largely deterministic
largely faded largely a connection of
causes but the human being in some
respects escapes that and perhaps there
Volition's and actions go right back
into that closet causality or causal
matrix
he doesn't clarify at this point we
don't have any writings of carnie otters
to tell one way or the other
Cicero considers what he has to say at
three points so let's look at the first
set of points carnie a Desmet maintains
that there is some voluntary motion of
the mind now for it to be voluntary
motion and he uses that word in in the
Latin means that we're choosing it means
that we're responsible for it means that
it's not completely determined but it
could be other we choose between
possibilities we endorse some of them we
commit to some of them and that is what
at least with some of the voluntary
motions the mind he's not saying every
motion of the mind is indeed like this
there could be all sorts of automatic
thoughts based on habit based on
instinct but at least some of them are
free and up to us or as Cicero will say
here in our power in notes remotest that
day right and these motions are not as
with the Epicureans without a cause in
fact they do have some sort of cause so
we do have causality working within the
universe and within ourselves but when
we will or when we will against Latin
has two words Vella the two will to
choose to select in some respects to go
forward with your will and then NOLA to
be unwilling to choose against to say no
to something
right whenever we're doing that Cicero
is saying that it's not as if it doesn't
have a cause at all but it doesn't have
to have what he calls an external and
antecedent cause for the willing that we
do in a certain respect although this is
not clarified very well here willing is
self causing and so kearney a day's
points out as Cicero is gonna have us
see a very important point that we don't
have to look at every single Clause as
being of the same sort so he says that
when we use the expression somebody
wishes or does not wish that's Bella or
NOLA something without cause we're
perverting we're changing the meanings
of the accepted convention of language
we're using the phrase without cause in
a restricted sense in the sense of
without an external something from the
outside without an external antecedent
cause not without a cause of some kind
and he says just like when we say a
vessel is empty we don't use the
expression in the sense in which it's
used by the natural philosophers who
hold that no absolute vacuum exists but
we say it doesn't have oil in it or
grain or wine or whatever so similar
when we say that the mind moves without
cause we're speaking in a somewhat
sloppy way what we really mean is that
it moves without an antecedent external
cause not without any cause at all and
so our own will our own choice what it
is that we do would be the cause in that
case now moving on Kearney RS is going
to make an argument that is going to
open up some scope for human freedom and
it runs like this if everything takes
place with antecedent causes causes that
come before it and if the cause is there
the effect has to be produced
right if everything takes place with
antecedent causes then all events take
place in a closely knit web of natural
interconnection and this is something
that quite a few philosophers would
accept that if there are in fact these
antecedent causes and they do in fact
produce their effects everything is all
connected together in this massive Nexus
of causal interconnections so far so
good
what are the implications of that if
that's the case then he says all events
are caused by necessity that is a
problem because if everything is caused
by necessity then how do we have any
scope for human freedom
if it really was the case that
everything happened by necessity by
external causes external antecedent
causes then nothing would be in our own
power nothing would be up to us nothing
would be within our control we wouldn't
actually be deciding in any real sense
we might feel like we're deciding but
we're not really making a decision
because you could say the decision has
already been made by the universe itself
or by whatever is necessitating us we're
not the ones actually making any
decisions but Kearney honest goes on
some things are in fact in our power and
so what are those things that are in our
power well Cicero discusses at one point
our desires as being potentially in our
power now of course that doesn't mean
every single desire that we have is in
our power but he calls it a patitos
right so our appetites or desires are
someone within our power but our
Volition's our choices are willing
that's definitely in our power that's
what it means to be volitional that's
what it means to be voluntary that it's
up to us that it's within our power when
we say well you couldn't have chosen
anything else
given the circumstances
chances and we really really mean it
we're saying the person didn't really
have a choice and it's not volitional or
volunteer it's involuntary right if I
try to punch at you and you jerk back
all of a sudden your body is doing that
that's not volitional but if you're a
well-trained fighter and I punch at you
and you choose to like block it instead
and then do some sort of counter that is
volitional even if it could be the
result of habit and training so some
things are in our power well that's a
problem for determinism not a problem
for determinism across the board and I
should mention here that this argument
doesn't say that everything is totally
random or nothing can be predicted as a
matter of fact it could be that 99.99999
and however decimal points you want of
the things within the universe are
strictly determined by causal necessity
or fate but so long as there's that
little bit so long as there's one human
being making voluntary choices or
decisions there's something that is
actually up to us that escapes that web
of causal necessity so what's the
conclusion to that he says if all events
take place by faith there's there are
antecedent causes of all events so it's
not the case that whatever events take
place take place by fate some things are
not fated it could be that almost
everything is but some things are not
and those are the things that in a
certain respect count the most now he
draws and this is the third point some
very interesting conclusions from this
and Kearney Addis here is arguing really
against the Stoics and against other
people the Stoics had thought that there
really was a necessity that ruled
everything and this is why divination or
consulting the gods is efficacious you
can find out what is going to happen in
the future
Kearney O'Day says no the god Apollo
who's the god of prophecy
can't actually tell you as much as you
think he can't in fact tell you because
he can't know about things whose causes
are so connected by nature that they
must necessarily happen so you know what
would be an example of that
he doesn't provide any here but you
could say well if you light you know
this match within these circumstances it
will start a fire there's probably some
sort of exceptions to that but let's
pretend that there aren't any exceptions
to that
Apollo could know that but does that
really do him any good no because when
it comes to all the things that people
consult Apollo about those tend to be
about what we typically call contingent
rather than necessary events so carnea
days says that Apollo can't tell any
future events except for these and he
says what consideration could lead the
God Himself to say that Marcellus who is
three times council was going to die at
sea this had indeed been true from all
eternity but it had no efficient causes
so Carney a days held the view that
Apollo had no knowledge even of these
past events which had left behind them
no trace of their passage how much less
had he had knowledge of future events
for only by knowing the efficient causes
of things that the causes that
necessitate things to be in a certain
way was it possible to know the future
so he says it was impossible for Apollo
to foretell the fate of Oedipus when
there were no causes for ordained in the
nature of things making it necessary for
him to murder his father nor could he
foretell anything of the sort
so Carney on a sphere is denying the
capacity to predict on the part of a God
who presumably would know way more about
the universe and causes than we human
beings do in our limited scope of
affairs so what we have here is not only
a defense of some measure of freedom of
choice or of the will but some
explanation about how this can be
you the case and how there can still be
causality rather than mere randomness or
indeterminacy provided by hernia days as
Cicero is representing him
you